he's Brian Scalabrine the Celtics
analyst comcast sportsnet New England
NBA analyst for the vertical and Bryan
joins us now Brian how are you feeling
today yeah I'm feeling pretty good after
that a terrible terrible loss of celtics
endure last night against the Hawks that
was historically bad Brian it was across
the board dan what happened they had
this momentum going into the playoffs
and this hasn't gone in scripted well I
think you're trying to see you know the
realities of the NBA playoffs in
positional size and how it comes into
play I mean Brad Stevens does a
fantastic job with these guys and Isiah
Thomas he's an all-star this year but he
is 59 and every time he drives to the
basket you could see it Atlanta swallows
him up when he gets to the rim and then
they play the weak sides so perfectly
not over helping sending three guys to
the ball and then playing guys in the
center field so well with Avery Bradley
out he's probably one of our best catch
and shoot players at least right now
because Jake Crowder has been a little
bit struggling with with the bad ankle
you know now Avery Bradley with him
being out it's really tough for us to
fabricate some offense I've been
defensively against to talk to you i
thought the celtics did a great job
overall just you know the first eight
possession atlanta was hot and they got
out and running but after that Brian for
good job on Ryan did you think did you
say us I I us a lot he had this felt it
yeah everyone's been telling me not to
do that but I just I feel since I travel
with the team and I do a lot of wiis and
us when it comes to that kind of stuff
well you do look like a Celtic you look
like you you know you did right in right
then I am I am mr. Celtic so yeah yeah I
uh Dan you think I shouldn't do that you
know I've gotten some advice from people
says it's not a good look what do you
think well are you all in on being a
Celtic announcer for the rest of your
career I mean if that's the way it goes
I'm definitely all in with that I had no
problem doing that I enjoy my job I
think you're bigger than just one team
though you
think I should treat them just like
every other team out there even though
I'm on the team plane you know like I
interview the coach every day we talk
you know like me and Danny would talk
for an hour before the game you know all
that stuff I throw all that out the
window well I think it's a fine line you
walk in all seriousness I I do think you
want to have credibility you don't want
to feel like Tommy Heinsohn we know is a
homer but you I just think you got to be
careful if if you're all in with the
Celtics and you don't care what that
criticism might be or is somebody going
to listen to you and say well yeah but
he's you know he's a Celtic Homer then I
wouldn't worry about it but if you see
yourself as and I see you as more of an
NBA guy a total NBA guy down the road
then maybe just with one team so that
would be my only advice is just be
careful with it because of people
reading into it or they're going to
identify you as well you're the Celtic
guy and if you know I probably don't
real where them yeah well they pay you
is that weird yeah they do sign my
checks as well is it weird that I do
root for but you know I would tell you
what I think it's not like I hold back
when I think about this team so you know
it is a fine line i agree with you and I
guess I'm starting to get to his advice
and people are saying the same thing if
you want to be known as a national guy
but you know what I do national stuff I
still sort of you know what you know the
Celtics are sort of my team I want them
to win I maybe maybe that's wrong I
don't know what's the meanest thing
you've said about silting oh I think
that when I don't think that we were
going to win this series in Atlanta like
if I from the very beginning I said it's
going to be hard for us to win this
series because we're just not that big
and if you want to win in the playoffs
you've got to be big and you know like I
see is great but he's 59 that's just the
reality of it so am I harsh on him I'm
when I'm calling a game I'm harsh that
they don't move the ball sometimes
defensively they're not picking up jeff
Teague the way they're supposed to so
yeah I am hard on them but you know no
difference in right then you just said
when they they see already dispatched or
the thought I'm not having an inclusive
one way I'm not exclusive us and read as
you go back and forth then I draw the
line somewhere all right we're talking
to Brian
abrini the white Mamba joining a Stan
Patrick show a couple other thoughts
here what if steph curry was actually
really injured and not able to play in
the playoffs what how would we but what
would be the angle that we would take
nationally with the Golden State
Warriors if steph was not able to play
at all all the way through the final
yeah let's just say that there was
something that showed up on that MRI
that let's say there was a hairline
fracture there do you think that we
would say yep see what happens going for
the record and all that stress and all
the wear and tear oh I mean some people
probably would but most people should
probably say like you know it's the game
of basketball it's sports and the
injuries happen I mean listen they along
the way I never thought that the
overextended themselves to you know to
get the record I always felt like they
kept it within you know the correct
minutes that they were playing even in
the playoffs they're not playing big
minutes look at these the Warriors route
teams so when for Steph Curry to go out
there and play 29 to 33 minutes it's not
going to tax them that much so I don't
think that ever be I'm sure people would
say that but that you can you can get
injured you know I in practice it's just
a world of professional sport yeah but
allocated right way yeah but that
wouldn't be the good story you know
people want to sell a store working yeah
they'd have to they'd have to blame
Steve Kerr you know Luke Walton for
planning too many minutes I mean you're
talking about when you say day you're
talking about the like uninformed media
of course you're talking absolutely yeah
here's another thing the UH the Oklahoma
City you have a terrible you know of one
of the worst shooting performances ever
for Kevin Durant had that been Russell
Westbrook shooting 74 33 how do would we
have been more critical if Russell
Westbrook 07 433 instead of Kevin Durant
and if so why yeah you know why because
most guys along the way and Kevin Durant
doesn't do this he doesn't waver from
his game if he's 74 33 or he's 15 for 33
he still plays the same way he takes
shot he doesn't lose his confidence you
know LeBron if he passes up a
game-winning shot
he just gets scrutinized by the media
but Kevin Durant is pretty solid along
the way now he may turn the ball over he
may take bad shots he make miss a wide
open layup which is slightly contested
at the end but he is who he is and I
think people can accept that for for
that now if he was in a bigger market I
think the local media would would be
harsher on her on him then than they are
but he's in okc and i think the people
there and give him a free pass because
of it but nationally kevin durant when
he plays bad you can't tell we're
watching the games he's always
aggressive he's all he's not afraid to
take the shot he doesn't care if he
missed his last 10 and i think people
can respect that a little bit from him
the team most likely to be Cleveland is
eight yeah go I mean anything and no in
the Eastern Conference you want me like
if you want to mr. conference you could
say Toronto but they got to get out of
Indiana here but uh I don't think any
team out east could be can beat
Cleveland I think they're gonna roll
thru the Eastern Conference Reggie
Miller was on the show and he said that
the guys from the TNT crew broadcast
crew if if they added Kobe could beat
the memphis grizzlies in a game Shaq
Kenny and Charles and Toby Chris Webber
Reggie Miller and don't forget about
Ernie Johnson right now that's what
that's what rich said I've uh no shot
name I bet you people would think that
you win but there's not they're not
beating memphis memphis that team
they're decimated by injuries yeah they
are not losing to Charles Shack Kenny
web regiment no way but you got Colby
though no you sure yet 60 the other
night out 50 shot damn I know who shot
he's gonna take this game you know ok ok
if you took 50 shot you tell me how many
she's scorer in the NBA if you are
allowed to get 50 shots and don't forget
the 20 free throws he took they really
went up around 60 something times so are
you getting 30 in a game dan I see you
shoot again 30 are they good is Utah
going to be guarding me if that's the
case then I'll gets 30 yeah they're
gonna be guarding okay oh yes then yeah
did it ever Donald another great way to
go out come on Dan it was a great way to
go out you take you get 60 some-odd
attempts because you know you fouled and
bailed out a couple times and you score
60 in your last game what a way to end
this terrible horrific season for Kobe
Bryant the most shot you took in your
NBA career in the game 17 17 17 i
thought that was alive with a 12 for 17
had 29 points in the NBA game and that
was i could I can't even imagine that I
mean but I mean I'm telling you he went
up to attempt around 60 times and he got
fouled you know and I'm and so don't
realize the amount of energy it takes to
create that many times I that's why I
tell people when they say you know
somebody shooting and I said each it's
hard to squeeze off 30 shots in a game
because yeah yeah oh yeah right i mean
you knew who was taking it and he still
was able to to put up that many shots
now gran not a great percentage but he
put up 50 shots that's hard to do it
it's hard especially when you're the guy
it's different if you're not the guy and
you stand in the corner and you get 5
there and you know you get a couple easy
layups from running the floor no it's
different when eyes are on you five guys
trying to stop you and you have the ball
in your hands you have to create a shot
is the most difficult thing in the NBA
to do and he was able to do it close to
60 times that game that was amazing if
you go back and forth and watch warriors
lakers on that night like no because I
decide what no because the lawyers was a
foregone conclusion it was like already
you already knew yeah you saw at first
five minutes of the game by the way
steph had 46 on 25 I know
well anybody get close to 81 I don't
think so the game the game now is so
different the days of isolation are
going away as we speak so you know this
more team basketball more ball movement
emphasis is on that so i don't i don't
think someone will get that thing you i
think a bigger number would be willing i
get seven be if somebody gets setting i
think that's a big big deal now but 81 I
think that's untouched well I think
that's like I thought I think Wilson
touchable out I think anyone's also
untouchable well 100 is nobody's going
to get to 100 but you know 81 is just I
mean that's mind-boggling on its own but
I wonder with the three with actually
more ball movement more transition
points that maybe you have somebody who
might have that if you have klay
Thompson going off and he gets a couple
of those quarters where he gets say 25
28 in in two quarters you know that
might be one of those part but still
have to have another onion I mean you
know like remember when he had 39 oh I
mean even if he did that 39 in a quarter
against Sacramento last season I mean I
can't imagine you just staying that hot
like Kobe has the ability to get to the
free-throw line he has the ability to
get to the basket and dunk on you and
and you know like clay is not that mean
it to be hot for that long with the
defenses and they might just send two
guys to try to take you away i mean i
can understand everything happening
Rodney hood we had 30 against the lakers
and a half but this should continue that
throughout the gaming to get close 81
that's just think that's insane but
doesn't mean you gotta shake a free
throws though I had you gotta shoot free
throws though that's that's hot that's a
line you have to line at least 20 you
got it like Jordan it was 30 years ago
Jordan had 63 on the celtics in the
garden and i think he had 13 in the game
but you know he shot a lot of free
throws no threes in the game no threes
in the game and he had 63 but you know
you gotta shoot free throws gotta gotta
but it doesn't the whole
you have all moving and teams that pass
the ball that's why the free throw
shooting has gone down like not you know
the temps have gone down because people
are sharing the basketball when you
drive in there and two guys it's not
okay anymore to go and force that shot
it right now it's the curses are telling
you make the extra pass don't tell
Michael Jordan to make the extra pass
from you had 63 it's great to catch up
with you as always have fun and make all
proud ago what what do you think no we
don't know I know because I don't want
to get in your hand O'Brien then you're
gonna be broadcasting and you're gonna
will we I mean they and I don't want you
to do that all right you are and we work
on that I'll work on that in the next
time we talk we'll see if you can you
trip me up but see you're I look at you
as bigger than one team so down the road
I like this I got a better way to look
at it Dan okay when you talk about your
dodge ram yes Yuri and us your dodge ram
like you don't actually work for dodge
but Yuri enough with dodge ram right
well I i we in us when it comes to all
my sponsors so well there you go
everybody is on my team alpha squad for
me yes everybody is on my team I dug and
they sign my check so they sponsor me
there you go good luck Friday night
thank you Brian all right there that's
Brian Scalabrine the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience